you can be seated
this is good pictures ragtime June first
of all that please compliment you on
your excellent taste in music and
Michael Jackson song that you came out
to its nominal groove so we'll just go
down the line and talk to everyone how
do you feel have you been man for a
while as you probably know because
you're you hear comic-con Ironman
anything
it just it just keeps getting better and
I'm so excited that we're all here this
is the longest bench of talent I've ever
been a part of and we gotta got real
nice movie coming for you guys next year
in terms of that's probably the first
time that you're actually I mean you're
genuinely part of this family of people
now it's ongoing yeah and I become a
little less significant every time which
is just what it is they're all so damn
good
yeah I'm wearing pants so now the event
now that you've done this a couple of
times the seem like old hat to you or is
it comfortable it still seemed exciting
and new well it's always thrilling it's
always like and then you think it's a
Friday next week and it's gonna be just
excited X Friday it's always a brand new
amazing thing glad to be here very honor
every day you go to work you go this is
strange that I get paid to do this every
day what I'm doing now no jerkbait was
promised compensation for gonna have to
discuss this but I mean just you know
getting over people and essentially
being a superhero for a job I mean the
truth is this is what you envision when
you're like I want to be an actor like
is this anywhere near what you thought
no meeting this guy over here he's the
one that convinced me and wash my car
easy to want to join was a great heart
convincing me to do it and never visited
but part of this amazing group of humans
sitting at this table yeah we did for
when the adventures first announced it
really wasn't a whole lot of footage and
we review our comic-con and you were on
the panel and at the time of your life I
don't really understand all this
comic-con stuff and what this is and you
did it and since then it completely blew
up to this exceed your expectations
is that that's really nice thank you
I'll crack just shame work all things
that you just have in public that people
don't even know who I am other than
Chris hey how's it going man you are an
exceptionally good shape
what is thorne meant to you
all this time I mean this is for me this
I think one of the best experiences I've
had on a set officer to work with this
group of people and to bring this
character to life and be part of this
madness is there anything that you
haven't done that's Thorian that you
feel like I just really want to do this
thing as though I really want Florida do
this tell you turn into a woman
to do this and people scream and cheer
and then and then you leave you get to
enjoy yeah not that you know going on
the floor or anything but it was my
first time doing is fighting these guys
are just pretty incredible to get to
meet people and sign pictures and kind
of connect for a second self excellent
and did you you didn't expect like this
would just keep going on and on for
Maria right yeah when Joss sort of
justice the one who kind of brought me
into this world and and I'm sorry it
can't be here I'm sure he wishes he
could be but yeah you kind of run games
with this girl that it's just been fun
just cute guy just keep going the TV and
I'm just I'm so grateful
Tim Jackson visit let me talk about your
like I bump into stuff a lot because of
my depth perception with the eye patch
so how do you feel like how do you think
Nick Fury would react to this type of
perception is is for now it's totally
amazing it's like every year I've been
coming here since I saw one Star Wars
seemed like every year I come here and
it validates it makes me feel like one
out making movies for rescue we we make
movies because we want to entertain you
guys
it's just images can we come back next
year with next that's it
then let's go over to my god what am I
gonna say what plants are gonna be
listening I I heard a story that I
wanted to confirm from you and I don't
know if it's true but I heard that when
you and Hemsworth we're sort of working
together then you you guys were like
comparing like muscle ribbons you're
like but how do you get this little
piece right here thanks Tony literally
he is four enormous it's it's it's it's
difficult to try and keep up keep up how
long how long is your workout magic CGI
congratulations on that success of
Winter Soldier yes do you feel like at
this point that Steve the captain is
like fitting does he feel more
acclimated to this world yet or does he
still feel a little isolated cell phones
in the internet he's up to speed but I
think he's still looking for a place to
belong seas for so long been a servant
fits in yeah there's a soldier he's used
to kind of this chain of command since
shield kind of fell apart the last
movies is more about this group of
people depending upon each other without
kind of a clear leader and I think he's
searching for home yeah
I'd like to welcome Aaron taylor-johnson
we just get a peek of a little bit how's
it felt coming into this established
world about people been working together
as kind of as the new guy yeah Freehan
Wellman and surreal and you know that's
it's a you know that y'all system all
guys approached me for this you know
don't hesitate it's huge you know it's
it's incredible to be a part of this
gang and great actors and was it was
there anything like a superhero film
that you never envisioned before like
what what's different about another
stuff that you've done yeah thinking I
mean it's just the the characters do you
have such a dynamic between you know the
group and I think we have what just
didn't the first one was we seemed like
a mission completely impossible to do
but everyone had that moment and stood
out and you know most beautiful is you
get these kind of characters in the same
room and they bounce
you know there's banter humor and it's
and then he has that tone where it can
be have a journey and be emotional and
sadder moments and you know like are in
an action-packed it's you know I
thoroughly enjoy all of Marvel movies